these factory workers are racing against
time trying to finish their day's work
before the curfew starts so they don't
lose their wages as the virus threatens
to wipe out their livelihoods once again
i'm scared of the curfew we eat as we
earn i'm a poor person and migrated from
a village to make a living i'm scared of
coronavirus and the night curfew
as covet 19 cases rise sharply several
states have imposed night curfews and
stricter testing rules for travellers
new delhi which has the highest number
of omicron cases in the country has been
put on yellow alert schools gyms and
cinemas have shut with new restrictions
on restaurants and public transport
the capital is preparing kovid 19 wards
and ramping up oxygen supply as the
third wave of infections is threatened
despite that markets have been crowded
the chief minister has implored everyone
to follow kovid 19 protocol
we don't want kovid 19 to spread yet
again and that is why we are repeatedly
making appeals that if you go out or go
to market or office please wear a mask
we have to be responsible but at the
same time don't be scared
the government has also expanded its
vaccination drive starting next month
over 15's will be eligible for a jab
while frontline workers and over 60s
with health problems can receive booster
shots the government has approved two
new jabs and an antiviral drug to treat
kobit 19. while india
is showing some indication of renewed
awareness and attention to respond to a
micron variant there is attention on
increasing vaccination coverage
and point of entry testing but as far as
covet appropriate behavior is concerned
there is a lot of room
or space for improvement
while infections and hospital cases
remain lower than in other parts of the
world the government says restrictions
will be increased if the infection rate
continues to rise while market traders
like these fear financial losses
political rallies continue in states
where elections are due early in the new
year that's provoking fears of a repeat
of so-called super-spreaded religious
gatherings and election rallies they
went ahead in the summer despite the
delta variant infecting millions of
indians pavni mithal al-jazeera new
delhi